okay guys so today i'm going to be
asking my siblings
who the favorite is okay just quick
question
who is your favorite sibling definitely
not you probably greg because he was to
hear the least amount of my childhood so
he annoyed me the most
okay so greg thank you amelia so what
happened to your other cat
dad put it in the garage and now it's
gone and like
what did dad say he felt bad or no he's
just like it's just a cat i'm just like
a cat i love that cat i've had that cat
for three months
amelia who's your favorite sibling
the cat amelia if we were all drowning
who would you say
come on
eva we're all drowning on we're all
drowning you one life raft who do you
send it to
nobody we all go down you inside to give
anyone you let us all die
who wants to live anymore it's 20 21
here
eva that is not the answer i was hoping
for
what kind of sandwich um can i do
something with like
eggs i mean
i don't care just make me something good
i trust you
you go with phoebe no
you know what i meant you know she pukes
from fred
oh she's a sausage that's not what i
meant
don't don't put the dog on the counter
here you go
what are you see okay you're cleaning up
her puke later
shouldn't you when i gave her a
quesadilla
okay eva
poor dog okay adam who's your favorite
sibling
definitely amelia okay now if we're all
drowning
on a boat we're off a boat
do you who do you throw the life jacket
to is it still going to be amelia
do i have to throw it can i just keep it
like no you got yours but you get to
throw one to like someone else
oh saving a family member yeah can i
keep it okay um eva kind of said a
similar thing
now who's your least favorite sibling
um that's that's an easy one
based off the fact that there's a camera
following me around in my own house
i'm never left alone to cook wings and
bees
i can't just enjoy a meal say it say it
say it say it say it
baby starts with an age
and she's definitely gonna overreact to
this
i am not the least favorite that's not
even true
who's your real least favorite stop
capping stop capping
i don't i i hate you all
cat